how did they love bomb the out of
you to tell you all the things that
needed to be heard to buy in because
where open books and we don't know that
we think we're so complicated and so
complex and it's written all over our
silly little faces anything you say
Canon will be used against you is
ammunition and torture later on they
find you and they idealize you then
you're drawn into a sort of a covert
contract with them through some sort of
bait now they need the bait will either
be money or fame or love or
um access to something it's pretty
demonic you know there's a lot of like
deals with the devil sort of thing like
contracts and all that that goes on once
they've got you you enter into a shared
fantasy space with them this was a this
the shared fancy was identified by a
psychotherapist called Sande in 1989.
all of us have a shared fantasy when
we're in relationships It's Perfectly
Normal and but the narcissistic shared
fantasy is a very dark one